il n'est plus nécessaire vous présenter
ses cli lui c'est fabrice di vizio ou
l'homme qui murmurait à l'oreille des
chevaux tiens un endroit où je m'énerve
jamais c'est à cheval arrivé en janvier
sûreté pmp d'être fabriquée vidéo merci
beaucoup il est surtout connu pour être
l'homme qui hurlait aux oreilles de ses
contradicteurs
donner cette chronique j'ai suffisamment
par les faiblesses et aux atouts outre
nous fait pas plus con boon est enfin mr
choix est là où m di vizio pattes les
provinces trépasse car oui fabrice est
devenu le porte drapeau incontestable
des antilles parce vous êtes
véritablement des résistants
et depuis sept semaines fabrice di vizio
est visé par le conseil de l'ordre pour
des manquements déontologiques suite à
une enquête du journal du dimanche une
enquête qui à bout c'est fabu division à
s'éclipser du monde médiatique il faut
que ça s'arrête un moment alors est ce
sa dernière apparition à l'écran ce soir
il a décidé de s'exprimer et de tout
nous dire dans tpm p
[Applaudissements]
non merci merci de répondre à nos
questions parce que c'est vrai que voilà
il ya plein de choses sur lesquelles on
est d'accord et vous il ya plein de
choses sur lesquelles on n'est pas
d'accord avec vous mais vous êtes quand
même fait partie de la famille et c'est
vrai que voilà et voilà ça nous a fait
de la peine tout ce qui est tout ce qui
a circulé sur vous toutes les
déclarations vous avez également sur
twitter alors déjà on va revenir sur ce
qui a été dit dans le jdd parce que ça a
été un moment difficile pour vous alors
les accusations du jd non je ne sais pas
on va dire on va on parce que personne
ne va là c'est comme la la presse est
très peu lu on va pas se mentir voilà
c'est vrai voilà on parlait de causeur
on parlait de la presse aujourd'hui
voilà il ya des journaux qui sont voilà
ce qui arrive à s'en sortir mais c'est
culte nc voilà cc c'est compliqué pour
la presse alors fabrice est présenté
comme le défenseur des antilles passe et
des antilles max ça ça vous dérange pas
tant que jeu présenté comme défenseur ça
ne va très bien d'accord même de
l'équipe de france merci et le jdd il
révèle les dessous de l'activisme de
fabrice di vizio un activisme qui
d'après leur enquête rapporte gros vous
pratiquiez depuis un an le harcèlement
judiciaire c'est ce qu'ils ont dit ça
veut dire quoi c'est croire seulement
judiciaire sur quoi c'est pas moi je ce
que je sais c'est que depuis un an je me
mets au service gratuitement tous ceux
qui me demandait qui sont soignants en
particulier parce que par le jdd
continuer à vendre ses articles pour un
confinement moi je défends des
absolument gratuitement tous ceux qui
m'ont demandé de l'aide soignant au
professeur de médecine chacun pendant
une souris à l'origine de 16500 plainte
déposée devant la cour de justice est
totalement fou c'est quoi c'est
totalement faux c'est une association
loi 1901 qui a été créée ssociation
effectivement permet aux citoyens
d'exercer la violence légitime par le
dépôt de plainte donc ça je rappelle que
je ne suis pas le seul à l'avoir fait
c'est c'est pas moi qui le fais si
l'association complètement dix thèmes de
mon cabinet légalement de manière
compétente en liga avait déposé ses 7500
je perds tu ne sais pas moi c'est les
citoyens qu'on accorde les pleins droits
qu'ont les fruits disent que c'est bon
alors mais ça je sais pas pourquoi
disent que c'est moi les mêmes personnes
que l'on attendait après des baisses ou
les gars y'a un truc et traversant la
rade et ils vous disent que je suis à
l'origine de la création du collectif
des médecins ses 19 et c'est
complètement débile enfin je dis ça fait
un an et demi qui les interroge le
collectif 7 19 c'est un collectif de
médecins qui s'est créé que j'ai défendu
j'ai pas de lien avec eux alors
origine de la mise en examen d'agnès
busan ça c'est vrai ah oui bah oui c'est
vrai parce que c'est les premières pubs
qu'on a déposé c'est nous qui avons
déposé les premières plaintes et on a
toujours dit que pour ce qui nous
concerne on a toujours respecté la
présomption d'innocence donc l'eau nous
il serait pas question de spéculer sur
quoi que ce soit mais qu'on avait un
droit constitutionnel de saisir la cour
de justice on l'a fait point alors vous
seriez aussi à l'origine de la
perquisition chez olivier verdoire
philippe et si bethesda leur sim et
n'diaye non mais d'or philippe et
olivier viron oui d'accord non parce que
c'est peut-être important pour la suite
j'ai pas déposé de plainte fautive et
n'diaye ils font des révélations
également sur votre business fabrice
division coup du dépôt de plainte sur
votre site entre 100 et 500 euros pour
les soignants mais ces gros bras pour
les autres ce que mais c'est faux c'est
radicalement faut c'est pas du tout un
dépôt de plainte c'est que les soignants
ce qui s'est passé c'est très clairement
avec l'obligation vaccinale nous avons
effectivement des gens qui nous ont
contactés pour plusieurs procédures et
nous avons fixé un tarif librement
consentie avec eux et fin de l'histoire
c'est pas des plaintes systématique que
les gens foncent et des recours qui
personnalise c'est à chaque fois des
tarés qui seront également discutés
enfin vous êtes déjà allé voir un avocat
vous savez combien ça coûte quand on me
reproche de prendre 100 à 500 balles on
rigole quoi alors comme hier et dément
je termine sur un point commun
deuxièmement dit avoir douze employés
mais n'en avait que trois accords mais
on va tomber on va tout faire un jeu
d'enquêté pas il dit avoir douze
employés mais n'en n'aurait que trois
ans cette année c'est que cette connerie
et qu'est ce que c'est que cette
connerie je venu à votre bureau il avait
plus que cela il a pu trouver c'est vrai
sans rigoler alors on
qu'est ce qu'on ferait à 3 dans 200 m² à
paris bah tu peux faire une boum
donc voilà il dit avoir rassemblé 6
rassemblé 600 médecins dans collectif du
19 mai il y en aurait que trois dans les
messages anciens de 3 à 6 ans nous va
bien c'est le gabon mais c'est pas mon
problème notre viande moi je suis là je
suis pas mais je suis pas membre du
collectif moi j'ai un collectif qui
vient de bois qui depuis un an et demi
dit qu'ils sont six ans que je crois
vrai parce que j'en ai eu un certain
nombre d'entre eux au téléphone d'accord
c'est à dire après s'ils sont trois ils
ont qu à les interroger des cas faire
son boulot quoi alors ils touchent rien
trop 8/10 humide et 25000 euros par mois
c'est depuis des années oui c'est mon
salaire d'un avocat ça va revenir à son
gérant d'accord c'est sympa de nos bons
ailleurs du secret médical comment ils
le savent ça mais j'en sais rien ils
disent que c'est moi qui leur ai dit ah
oui parce qu'ils disent aussi que je
travaille décidemment il manque la fin
18 à 25 milles par mois à mi temps
d'accord je fous rien de mes journées
donc pas qu'à faire bon ils comptent tmp
ouais
vos condamnations il parle de vos
condamnations 6 motif avoir présenté une
collaboratrice comme avocate alors
qu'elles n'étaient pas inscrits aux
barreaux puisque d'un mois les gens qui
ont des gens qui m'appellent mon cher
confrère il signe un contrat de
collaboration entre avocats qui sont pas
avocat on m'a demandé on m'a dit que sa
mode vérifier diplômes aux clés dont
acte maintenant je vérifie les diplômes
points d'accord pour votre bien ne pas
avoir averti le bâtonnier qu'il ouvre
une antenne en italie c'est quoi cette
histoire basques qui sauvaient ce qui se
passe c'est donc déjà c'est vrai que la
cabine est à rome et ce qui se passe et
que le bâtonnier dit que le bâtonnier
avait dit que je ne l'ait pas informé
dans les formes ce qui était en effet
vrai je n'ai pas respecté les feux le
formalisme imposé par lot pour la
déclaration dont kevin en italie c'est
vrai en effet et vous avez été condamnée
à 18 mois d'interdiction d'exercice en
juillet 2015 à la profession d'avocat
pourquoi six mois est pourquoi tu te
présenter je me suis présenté à rien les
cordonniers sont les plus mal chaussés
je le dédie à l'express à leur place je
me ferais radiés parce que quand on se
présente pas à des audiences
disciplinaires quand on se présente pas
à des enquêtes qui sont faites faut pas
s'étonner après que les gens
effectivement je me suis défendu comme
une merde pas je me suis rendu comme une
merde mais de quoi un dépendu de coire
défendu l'accusé sont pas des cons comme
aux maliens mais cette accusation sur la
collaboratrice sûrs je me suis jeté à
l'eau je me suis pas présenté mais se
représenter je peux pas je peux pas
demander à des gens et du coup quand je
suis passé en appel du coup je me suis
présenté cette fois ça donnait ça
d'accord très bien
on a aussi vous avez obtenu six mois
avec sursis après et le 14 septembre sur
twitter vous avez annoncé votre retrait
de la vie plus
terminé c'est quoi vous en avez ras le
bol de tout ça de tout d'être sais c'est
pas que j'en ai ras le bol si oui il ya
que deux façons de faire moi
contrairement à eric zemmour
contrairement à son personnage public je
ne nourris pas si vous voulez de la
vindicte et c'est pas du tout mon
objectif moi je crois dans ce que je
fais c'est la première réalité vous avez
été dépassé par tout ce qui s'est passé
à cause d'eux afin qu'on s'est passé
c'est autre chose il va revenir mais
dépassés c'est pas ça c'est qu'à un
moment donné je me suis pris un certain
nombre d'articles successifs dans la
gueule pour faire simple et bon j'ai des
enfants voilà je me balade à gaza et
protection rapprochée depuis des mois
donc à un moment donné vous dites ça
s'arrête quand et donc pourquoi ça
s'arrête vous avez reçu beaucoup de
menaces beaucoup le mot est faible accor
ou le moins il fait vos devoirs ti-cul
l'avant droit que je défends raout on
voudrait avoir depuis qu' il allait
faire rouler ma tête en gros
effectivement qu'il savait où j'habitais
qui saboter scolariser mes enfants que
voilà que défendre des charlatans il
fallait forcément que ça il faut que je
me doute que c'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle
est arrivée enfin voilà donc bon qu'à un
moment donné vous vous dites je fais
quoi est-ce que je continue comme ça
pendant des années ou est-ce que si
j'arrête ça s'arrête le salit des mois
je m'en vais la personne j'ai hockey le
combat dans lequel je crois je compte
unique roire ses combats contre le pass
sanitaires et c'est mon droit et à
partir de là je suis je vais organiser
les choses différemment sauf que je me
suis aperçu d'un truc entre les deux qui
me pose un problème énorme c'est qu'en
fait depuis que j'ai dit que j'arrêtais
les attaques elles se sont donc pliés en
fait bfmtv enquête sur moi on me parle
d'une enquête déontologique ça c'est
extraordinaire on me parle d'une enquête
déontologique contre moi je dis bah non
c'est pas mal d'entre eux m'a écrit que
c'était pas vrai loeb ne me dis que
c'est écrit que c'est pas vrai je ne
peux pas produire le courrier parce que
ses couverts par le secret des
correspondances et journalistes me dit
ah si vous ne trouvez pas fabrice des
vidéos que vous avez été dépassé par le
système partout les gens qui je ne suis
dépassée par rien je suis dépassée par
glenn humain je suis dépassée par la
haine et par le fait qu' on est dans un
système complètement haineux mais
regretter tout ce que vous avez je ne
regrette notre argent doit être
absolument rien et ce d'autant qu'en
réalité parité pmp ce que je sais de
source sûre alors on va en parler juste
après parce que
benjamin castaldi va nous dire ce qu'est
ce qui là aussi comme source sûreté pmp
et pourquoi on la tacc autant oui ben
j'aurais visible mais je suis donné que
pas trouvé le grain brion que vous
découvriez maintenant après avoir quand
même été ne sont tous les plateaux de
france et navarre que ce monde est un
peu cruelle que les gens sont méchants
méchants et que tout ça est un est un
monde de ses seins parce que je suis
franchement et donner parce que vous
pouvez naïveté confondante peut-être
parce qu'elle n'avait pas ce que c'est
pourquoi honnêtement pas ce que je vais
vous avez une vraie une vraie bien dit
qu'on voulait toujours un plateau il a
semblé victime s'étonnant que c'est
pourquoi j'ai pas un soupçon de
méchanceté message alors ça j'en doute
pas à briser à jamais parler d'hystérie
nations du débat mais vous savez partage
en temps tu dois t'en dire si on marque
est gelée complètement reconnu et j'ai
dit effectivement gelé complètement
reconnu et j'ai dit que en effet mais en
même temps je suis pas le seul
responsable wisteria sont bien là et ce
qui est perturbant si vous voulez c'est
que je dis je m'en vais hockey balle au
centre lire on récupère effectivement un
peu puisque apparemment aussi stériles
au débat pas fini de moteur que déjà je
me fais attaquer toutes parts ah oui
mais ça ça va pas être possible c'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne moi ça
fait un an et demi que j'ai deux voies
qui s'offrent à moi la première est de
me taire effectivement je ne rien dire
c'est ce que j'avais choisi j'en ai une
deuxième qui est celle de dire je parle
et je parle différemment et je parle
effectivement en utilisant des sources
différentes et à partir de maintenant
j'ai une parole publique qui est une
parole publique que je maîtrise
complètement de bout en bout et je vais
vous dire après l'attaqué jeudi dans la
gueule depuis je me tais il n'est pas
question de continuer à me taire c'est
pas possible c'est parce que c'est pas
possible parce que si je me tais et que
d'autres continuent de taper bayadère
libre n ya pas de solution gilbert des
mois j'ai une info vous concernant elle
m'a déçu et je voulais la confronter
avec vous aujourd'hui j'ai eu deux
avocats qui vous connaissent donnerait
pas leurs manches et pas mes sources qui
m'ont dit qu'en fait que votre retrait
l'été stratégique il ya un et autour de
vous il ya des pressions il ya des
articles vous avez senti que votre
business et est fragilisé et en fait que
vous auriez accepté de vous retirer
d'arrêter de parler d' arrêter de
fracasser le gouvernement en échange
d'une sorte d'impunité tais toi tais toi
fabrice di vizio et entre laissera
tranquille ça m'étonne de vous mais je
voulais vous poser la question de boeck
effectué au japon sur ce point je ne
cède à rien jamais je n'ai reçu aucune
menace en tout cas du gouvernement ou
que salam implicite au même implicite
les seules choses si voulez moi mon
souci mon équilibre il se trouve autour
de ma famille c'est tout en fait et vous
parliez d'une naïveté benjamin
effectivement je vous la conseille
volontiers gm naïveté parce que moi
quand j'ai une parole publique et que je
viens ici je des domaines pour personne
on n'est pas d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord mais j'ai un profond respect
pour chacun ah oui le dire heures c'est
parce que vous avez dans vos tweets bien
sûr mais c'était après mai mais c'est le
jeu dont vous est pris aux lions et
d'anglais de jeu c'est un jeu vous avez
accepté vous avez joué je
vous dirais même ajouté sur twitter
pendant plus vous l'avez fait certaines
familles qui vous a demandé de vous
retirer non alors ma famille
effectivement en l'occurrence elle me
laisse le choix ce que je fais un carré
jaude maintenant je réponds qu'un
complètement à ça moi si vous voulez ce
qui me pose qui me pose une difficulté
dans cette affaire c'est qu'on a tous
des spéculations sur la raison pour
laquelle je m'en vais la raison pour
laquelle je réclame être plus
stratégique je vais vous dire on peut
toujours le dire mais la raison pour
laquelle j'ai dit que je partais c'est
parce que vraiment je pensais que en
partant on allait avoir une forme
d'apaisement du débat quand je me rends
compte mac os est pas le cas fabre
division qui nous a dit qu'il arrêtait
la vie publique le 14 c'était le 14
septembre aujourd'hui ce que vous avez
échangé des
jets pas changé d'avis g
comment je vais dire aux gens les na'vi
j'ai pris acte des queues de ce que si
je m'arrêtais ça ne s'arrêtera pas
d'accord que en gros c'est terminé la
nationalité aux rideaux gilles verdez on
vous a dit vous mettez sur le côté vous
arrêter et ça va bien se passer pour
vous elle est pas bonne non elle est pas
bonne je les ai pensé que ce serait bon
giro niveau géant disant ok si je
disparais du paysage médiatique jeu
disparaît du paysage public et bien tout
ça va toutes ces attaques ad hominem que
je subis bon c'est s'étioler bon
effectivement disparaître et je me rends
compte qu'en fait mais ce ne sera pas le
cas mais il faut du temps non mais il
faut encore éteindre le feu joseph oui
mais alors le feu s'ils voulaient trader
ou du taux pour le faire aussi attendus
je n'ai pas commencé
finalement regarder c'est intéressant
lundi le 12 au matin jeudi j'arrête je
suis chez mardis jeudis j'arrête machin
j'explique pourquoi l'après-midi bfm
m'appelle on va dire vous pensez quoi de
l'anc est bientôt logiquement conquis en
cours contre vous et quelle enquête
déontologique de quoi vous ne rien
manquer j'adore on me dit mais bien vous
a coûté bien on m'a dit oui mais bon
écoutez nous on a nos sources bah
écoutez si vous avez vos sources très
bien moi qui suis je vous dise moi j'ai
pas répondre à quelques choses dont
j'ignore même l'existence et tout part
comme ça aujourd'hui 206 plus possible
de répondre alors contacter si vous êtes
un must d'athus je ne font dire quoi que
pourrait pour cette question mon propos
était très clair j'ai en moi
je rends pour coup pour coup y'a pas de
problème a juste dans pour de longs mois
j'avais dit ok si ça s'arrête je
m'arrête ya pas prêt à faire si je
m'arrête quand s'arrêteront à cypress
arrêté au caire où j'ai compris à partir
de maintenant on leur fixe les règles
alors c'est quoi les rives des règles je
donne pas pour l'instant mais quand vous
les aurez même doivent atteindre arcand
les règles
se couchent médias qu'un média
indépendant c'est une des règles
d'ailleurs que vous donnez 80 sont des
prises de parole elles vont être limités
et donc tu auras les règles vont tomber
y'aura elles vont tomber demain à la
manif que vous inquiétez pas je
reviendrai ici pour le coup d'accord
vous les donner parce que ici je voulais
revenir par rapport aux versions tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait mois les
rumeurs aussi j'en ai et je sais que je
vais être emmerdé un moment donné par
l'ordre pas du tout pour les questions
avaient relations financières qui sont
n'importe quoi mais parce
qu'effectivement j'ai une parole aux
tons qui est un problème et en
particulier dans cette émission je le
sais et je sais qu effectivement c'est
l'histoire des mépris de classe et je
sais qu'en fait on ne reproche
finalement à défaut de quoi me reprocher
le fond de vos propos on me rapproche de
la fin l'emblème bnp en fait on est
heureux en allemand je le sais je ne
suis pas du moi aussi j'ai mes sources
je fais ce métier depuis suffisamment
longtemps et je sais que ça va du bois
on vous dit quoi on me dit qu'en
substance on a décortiqué mais passage
ici et notamment avec un dépassé avec
matthieu delormeau voyez je le sais où a
effectivement dans lequel je dis qu'ils
racontent des conneries et que c'est pas
bien de dire qu'on raconte des conneries
c'est pas déontologique de zac raconte
des conneries même si c'est vrai
et est donc effectivement on l'a repris
certains passages de l'émission de
l'année dernière moi j'en suis là je le
sais je suis pas du château en fait que
ça va pas tarder vous avez dit une
équipe qui avait un problème fait voilà
ils voulaient m'attaquez également et
attaquer les missions bas en tout état
de cause si vous voulez ce qui est très
claire dans ce propos mois au terme des
éléments qui sont en leur possession
encore une fois puisqu'on joue à pas
dévoiler ses sources ne voit pas nos
sources c'est à dire eh bien ce que je
sais moi c'est incontestablement
derrière les accusations qui me visent
ce qui est visé c'est uniquement la
question de savoir aujourd'hui si le
format de l'émission est digne pour un
avocat de mon rang autres maires général
a participé régulièrement une émission
de cette nature est une émission
populaire qui est une émission dans
laquelle on dit les choses avec respect
mais on les dit crûment parfois parce
que c'est le langage de la rue et je
vais vous dire c'est gilles verdez
l'année dernière qui m'a dit quelque
chose de vraiment intéressant pour le
coup ils veulent être sûrs et à bientôt
à une époque où effectivement la
question de revenir me poser problème
mais c'est lui qui m'a dit il faut
revenir parce qu'il faut qu'on ait des
contradicteurs il faut qu'on soit
capable de débattre et même de scruter
il faut qu'on soit capable de le faire
et ben et ses intérêts de cette émission
c'est quoi on est capable de se friter
maintien on peut se friter et ça fait
avancer de demain
oui c'est pas la première fois que c'est
pas les chemises de caméléon sur ton qui
pose problème n'en fabrique c'est pas la
première fois que vous dites que vous
arrêtez tout et finalement vous
n'arrêtez pas sans moi j'ai énormément
de respect pour vous mais est ce que
vous vous comportez pas un peu comme une
rock star à dire j'arrête ou non ont
ouvert supplier par vos fans et revenir
c'est un peu ça remet non je vais vous
dire je vais vous dire moi je sais pas
mais j'avais dit que j'arrêtais des pmp
pas même chose mais vous êtes revenu et
je suis revenu parce qu'on a posé de
nouvelles règles simon couvre c'est
aussi simple que ça puis vous n'étiez
pas là comment sait pas ce
qui a battu on a une leçon
d'égocentrisme
vous votre égocentrisme vous fait le
show en permanence vous avez de quoi
vous parlez
[Rires]
il ya désormais en tête derrière et qui
chercheraient ce qui se passe autour de
vous et puis aussi alors lundi jalons
départ c'est la madonna des barreaux
j'annonce mon départ a dit depuis mardi
je pense que peut-être je reviens et
attention aujourd'hui annonce il annonce
que demain il donnera ses comptes
ces conditions n'est pas évident mais
c'est génial alors ça c'est génial parce
qu'en fait c'est débile
c'est bien c'est génial d'avoir une tête
qui se ridiculise comme ça parce que
pour le coup petit moi moi ce que je
suis en train de vous dire j'étais à ce
gentil monsieur à côté moi c'est simple
en fait à un moment donné quand vous
faites des mouvements et des vous fais
défoncer par l'express wen défoncer pour
des menaces de mort à mayence est arrivé
à abandonner paris ou dit ok non je sais
qu'il a pris beaucoup de trucs dans la
gueule
permanent setca maroc c'est qu'ils se
mettent tout en scène pour on va dire
parce qu'on se met en scène servat
torsion des menaces de mort mais c'est
tout ce que je dis c'est que le jdd sort
des accusations je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai ou faux j'en sais rien mais vous qu
est toujours grande gueule au moment où
tous nos comptes commencent à vous
accusez non
pas le plus ça n'a rien à voir n'importe
quoi vous raconter n'importe quoi parce
qu'effectivement vous situe pas l'année
dernière et que vous connaissez pas
alors de grâce évitez de raconter
n'importe quoi est ce que concrètement
effectivement le problème qui se pose
depuis un an en tout cas depuis quelques
mois maintenant c'est que nous avons une
hystérisation j'en conviens que c'est
les règles du jeu et que j'ai sans doute
contribué à la différence c'est que j'ai
mené à ces personnes pour ce qui me
concerne à la différence c'est que j'ai
pas envoyer de mails de menaces de mort
pour ce qui me concerne c'est ça la
différence à la différence c'est que
j'ai pas aller j'ai parlé effectivement
sortir les poubelles des années alors
tant mieux si vous êtes habitués moi non
et je suis désolé d'avoir encore du mal
à m'y habituer alors c'est la dernière
partie de l'émission merci oui la
question d'aller en retrait de la vie
publique mais pas abandonnée - vente
voulais me rendre compte tout d'abord
bien ne faudrait pas non d'accord ce que
vous dites jeudi qu' apparemment il
avait mis en vente sur les listes de
choquer à mettre en vente et ses séries
voiture au bout
oui après c'est un dossier sur lequel
vous n'êtes pas clair du tout c'est ce
qui concerne le barreau de paris vos
collègues avocats parce que vous dites
j'ai la preuve j'ai la preuve que le
conseil de l'or n'a pas diligenté une
enquête contre moi oui mais selon mes
informations il ya un examen approfondi
s'est passé
mais répondez moi mais c est il un
examen approfondi de vos affaires qui
est en cours et alors d'accord ces trois
ans comptable mais d'abord première
chose dont je ne confirme rien selon vos
informations elles sont sur france info
génial les infos
assez profonde ou qui le dit alors huit
mois fabrice est ce que yann et qu'est
ce qui avait conduit et qu'est-ce qu'il
casse avec au programme mais savez vous
répondez pas à la question ya maintenant
je n'en sais rien approfondie ce cas là
je n'en sais rien je vous aimerai que
marc moi ça c'est que oui baba voyez il
sait que oui et donc il attend des
jumeaux
oui le mec il est 20 heures ils
balancent au public que je faisais une
enquête selon un examen approfondi des
lamelles pourrait comme moi tes
conneries landais et comment voulez vous
que je veux défendre face à ça et je
vous montre passionnait
fabrique il ya pas mal de gens qui
posent cette question est-ce que vous
assumez d'avoir comparé le pass annie
terre un viol en disant vous avez 16 18
ans vous êtes en relation avec quelqu'un
un jour il va vous dira j'associe
attendant l'autorisation louis saïa
porte je veux un acte sexuel c'est
pourquoi les nations unies
les dérives et même internet en
détendant pas raison qui est au jeudi à
permet la comparaison est l'une des
raisons est ce qu'elle est les gallois
ce qu'elle n'est pas
mais attendez mais ce
débat est ce qu on a droit donné à paris
par exemple à brive pas vous savez très
bien qu'en disant ça il ya des femmes
qui meurent gardons des hommes peut-être
qu'ils ont été violés qui vont dans leur
chair ne pas supporter ce que vous venez
de dire repart et appâts sanitaire qui
est ce qu'il ya une vocation dont la der
on n'adhère pas mais la vocation du
passé n'était recettes protéger les gens
sans dire vous le chef du protégé
je dis que je dis qu'effectivement en
philosophie morale les choses sont très
claires ce que je fais c'est de la
philosophie morale et que moi j'y peux
absolument rien si vous avez choisi de
déporter le débat sur le terrain de
l'émotion en permanence et jamais sur le
terrain de l'as rien et que si on doit
se limiter à chaque fois son entreprise
de parole en se disant mais comment
est-ce que mon propos d'être accueilli
par l'hôte sur le plan émotionnel
violent vous étonnez pas s'il sera de
retour certainement mardi pour fixer les
règles du jeu les connaissez avant parce
qu'ils les annonces de magna donner sa
[Rires]
réponse a est ce que les gestes ratés
mission comme et qui quand même bien ils
ont quand même c'est que quand même
finalement on est capable de raconter
des débilités
pas cher à nice vous savez je capte tout
le temps que l'année dernière oui en
l'occurrence que je veux dire ici
aujourd'hui c'est que ce mépris dans
lequel vous m'étonnez et bien tout à
l'heure par les leviers cette
comparaison est là qu est ce qui fait
depuis tout à l'heure qu'est ce qui fait
finalement de puteaux l'heure sinon
distiller le mépris c'est ça la vérité
mais rend con ex collègues issus du
terrain je termine toutefois on explique
juste que fondamentalement est quand
même en donner une pression absolument
je dois m'en sur abl je suis dit et on a
quelqu'un qui se fout de ma gueule
pardon
est-ce qu'il se trouve drôle moi j'ai
dit qu'aux qg bon
bah c'est un problème avec ça voilà
alors mal rires la souffrance des autres
c'est toujours un problème alors ça vous
grandit pas tellement et vous êtes déjà
pas très grand
[Applaudissements]
les répondants mais le vrai problème là
si on est si on est sérieux deux minutes
le vrai problème justement c'est que
c'est un sujet sérieux et que ce
monsieur tournent tous autour de lui
alors nécessaire
maintenant et vous fascine toujours one
man show permanent str autour de sujets
alors vous verrez que c'est beau jour
pour ici pas à côté de ça les mêmes
éléments non merci ça sujet sérieux
arrêtez d'en parler
[Applaudissements]